Viruses, they really want to take over a cell
because interestingly viruses don't have all
of the things
that they need to make copies of themselves.
And, like everything on this planet in order
to continue being present on this planet
we all have to make a copy of ourselves, right?
And that's why people have children,
that's why pets have babies,
that's why bacteria will divide,
and you know-- expand their population.
Viruses also need to do that or else they
won't exist anymore, right?
And so viruses actually will use the things
that we have already inside of our cells.
So, our cells have all these amazing machines,
like proteins and other things that can make
different copies of cell pieces.
And, so viruses come into our cells,
and they basically like hijack all of that
stuff,
so that it'll take over our cells,
so that we can make copies of their pieces,
so that they can continue making sure there's
always more viruses being made.
And, so when that happens to our cells in
a way that really hurts
our cells we end up having an immune response.
Sometimes our immune response just gets rid
of the virus right away,
and sometimes we need a little extra help
from meds.
And, so that's why viruses get us sick.